thank you Tom for that kind introduction
so you know Tim gonna talk about the
blockchain and why it's actually
interesting and why it means value is
now programmable all right so why why do
we think blockchain is you know the most
important technology this decade you
know Tom gave my bio I won't you know
belabor it but basically currently CG
oakland-based part two that sold a
company to coinbase
earn part of that general partner at
anderson Horowitz you may be familiar
with the firm we also sold a company for
about 300 75 million dollars
it's a genomics company literally came
out of BIOX just you know down the
street over there with my brother and a
bunch of our friends and basically just
you know a Stanford guy through and
through so you know I kind of know your
your pain so assess me but never met me
let's talk about Bitcoin and watching so
I like this particular image because I
think it motivates you know this is a
screencap of Wireshark and you can see
the Bitcoin protocol literally as as a
protocol on screen and what's amazing
about this is you can see that payments
have been turned into packets right this
is you know a transmission you know this
is a Bitcoin block you can see the bytes
over here and what's remarkable about
this is what's absent right there's no
there's no HSBC there's no Wells Fargo
right there's no countries there's no
you know licenses or anything like that
right what we have done is literally
digitized the transmission of value and
if you think about how big a deal it was
to digitize books and music and movies
and newspapers and and so on and so
forth the the underlying technology
behind blockchain allows us to size now
cash stocks bonds mortgages loans
derivatives and all kinds of new things
financial instruments that you haven't
even maybe thought of yet so so this is
you know really like the the motivating
thing once once we've got something into
the realm of computer science well all
you folks can go to town so there's
gonna be a lot of fun in the next 10
years all right so I'm gonna give you
know basically ten things about
blockchain ten things about coin base
and go through a FAQ and certainly
answer all your all your questions so
just about coinbase about blockchain I
want to review Bitcoin blockchain and
aetherium and then talk about Columbus a
little bit and do your Q&A so first you
know just for those folks just a level
sex under those varying backgrounds I
want to give the very very very basics
in particular this slide over here is if
you only remember one slide and you know
don't want to remember anything else
this is the motivation behind why even
invent Bitcoin in the first place right
so you know with physical cash right if
I have a dollar bill and I hand Tom that
dollar bill there's an implicit property
of the dollar bill which is when a hands
that dollar bill to be ain't no longer
has it and be Hazzard right
I had it then now Tom hasn't anybody
who's observing that can see you know
that that physical bill was handed over
if I try to naively transplant that to
the digital realm okay if I take the the
Federal Reserve serial number so on that
dollar bill and I just go and email them
to Tom okay well I still have a copy of
those serial numbers and I can go and
email them to somebody else okay and
that is the fundamental issue with a
naive representation of digital cash it
is the double spend problem I could have
spent those serial numbers with Tom and
then with somebody else and somebody
else and so simply using serial numbers
alone that's not sufficient for for
basically scarcity in the digital realm
and so so the way that we until the
invention of Bitcoin the way that we
represented digital cash was with a with
a bank right like a centralized actor
that we trusted in the middle and this
actor over here is where the scarcity
enters the system right when a sends
money to be digitally see is trusted to
debit a and to credit B right this is
where the the scarcity enters the
equation the thing about this is you're
putting a lot of trust in C right they
can debit and credit anybody they can
choose not to debit or credit they can
not you know allow a transaction to go
through in extremis I was in you know
2008 you know they could print billions
of dollars for themselves and so so this
is something which is you know inelegant
from a computer science perspective to
have a trusted central node if you can
if you can avoid it
and so what's Trisha Nakamoto did is he
came up with D decentralized digital
cash and so essentially this
central actor this this Bank was
replaced with a network of miners and
any one of those miners could approve
that transaction that debit or credit
between a and B and so since any one of
them could approve it one of them
disapproving it you know all they would
just do is be giving up some Bitcoin
that they would have mined otherwise
it's basically way to combine
transaction approval and and Senor Ridge
currency printing in the same unit so
the details of this aren't super
important you know like technically you
know at least for talk like this but the
concept is important which is we took
physical cash we tried to naively turn
digital cash that didn't work so we had
these centralized actors and Bitcoin
dispenses with those centralized actors
by having anybody in theory who can
connect to the internet with sufficient
computational power can approve
transactions and push them through okay
so the the cool thing about Bitcoin is
once people understood this and once
people understood what a breakthrough it
was they said oh well you know this data
structure that that these miners are
updating that blockchain that
fundamental innovation behind Bitcoin
that's essentially a tamper-resistant
database for storing arbitrary things of
value you can use it for certain cash
and you can use assuring stocks and
bonds and and so on and so forth but
Bitcoin itself wasn't that easy to work
with it wasn't wasn't built for
programming or it was actually but
Satoshi turned off a lot of the more
sophisticated op codes early on just
just to keep it you know simple and
attack proof and so what happened was
more recently a new blockchain was
launched in 2014 called aetherium about
five years after launch of Bitcoin and
to understand the improvement that
aetherium gives here's an example like a
script in Bitcoin which is kind of
almost like a sembly language like a
stack based language and here's what you
know a theorem solidity looks like which
is a little more you know like like
English or JavaScript or what-have-you
and this program ability led to a huge
new surge in crypto activity and in 2017
about this massive ICO boom and this
went up you know from like you know on
there were tens of billions of dollars
to many hundreds of billions of dollars
and then down to one hundred billion
dollars but the thing about this is you
know even though like the the ICO is
like came up and they went
you know we think of it today it's you
know it's a winter for price but the
summer for innovation a lot of the stuff
that kind of got started back then is
starting to work you know for example
you know you've got decentralized
prediction markets and decentralized
loans and decentralized derivatives that
stuff is all starting to work you know
the winter for price the summer for
innovation one thing that I SEOs
themselves by the way is they represent
in my view the simultaneous disruption
of venture capital Swift crowdfunding
and cap tables and I'll come back to
that point but essentially you can
invest in something internationally with
a group at the same time and have all of
the property rights recorded in the
blockchain so anybody can see that's
like such a big deal and so many
innovations at once that people can
sometimes lose a forest for the trees
because they say oh you know what are
you funding you're funding all this you
know crazy stuff but if you just look at
it as an innovation in crowdfunding or
NBC or or Swifter cap table it's
actually a pretty big deal okay so this
this brings us to the present day so you
know it was Bitcoin then the blockchain
then aetherium I see a boom and now the
present day the crypto winter winter for
price summer for innovation okay
so you know the way to think about the
blockchain is the technologies it
improves fundamental financial
primitives and one way of thinking about
this is you know blockchain as I
mentioned it's a database for storing
things of value and it started with
cryptocurrency which is like digital
gold and you know more recently we've
had you know these so-called GRC
twenties tokens or chirps and like
equities but you can also use it for
other stuff right you can use it for non
fungible assets like you know so-called
it's very technical sounding like
in-game items like swords and potions
you know baseball cards collectibles or
even you know eventually a piece of real
estate right you can use it for
representing identity and frankly you
can use it for representing almost
anything scarce anything scarce you can
think of you can represent in a
blockchain and you might say well why
why use the blockchain for things that
are scarce well once you've got a
database that represents all the money
in the world
the first thing someone's gonna try to
do is write themselves a million dollars
right and so you have to actually say
well first I want it to be tamper
resistant second I don't want one party
to be able to write themselves a million
dollars I want it to be decentralized
right so that
that the power is split no one person
can write themselves a million dollars
they might need more than a million
dollars strengthen cells a million
dollars and once you start thinking of
those kinds of constraints like a
database that represents things of value
you start to be led to the kinds of
properties that blockchains have and
once of course you can solve the problem
of preventing someone from writing
themselves a million dollars you can
stop them from writing themselves a
million potions or million acres or a
million of anything else so as I
mentioned before you know like Bitcoin
turned all the stuff into into packets
right there literally protocols
you know Bitcoin etherion you know these
things in that you can open up Wireshark
and see the raw packets at update the
underlying block chains right it's just
it's actually completely amazing when
you think about that um anybody who's on
the Internet can send and receive
cryptocurrency back and forth you know
just send packets back and forth um
one consequence of this is you know
there's there's another you know people
have talked about the unbanked and it's
you know it's important problem that I
think crypto can solve in the long term
there's another group of unbanked which
are which are machines and you know we
gave machines telephone numbers in the
form of IP addresses it used to be that
you had to have a human who's associated
the telephone number when you give a
machine an IP address a machine and then
autonomously communicate back and forth
right and you do that all the time
whenever you written a bot that goes and
interacts with Twitter or scraper you
know like that spider's web and connects
to other you know computers autonomously
autonomous machine communication was a
really big deal and we believe that
autonomous machine transaction where
machines can hold and send money on your
behalf will likewise be a very very big
deal right here is just in a simple you
know get up just that you know string
over there represents money right so if
you can now transmit a string you can
transmit an arbitrary amount of value
which is pretty awesome so a lot of the
stuff in the late 90s and people talked
about where they talk about intelligent
agents or like bidding entities and so
on that's all actually starting to
happen
the primary context in which it's
happening are things like you know
exchanges especially decentralized
exchanges you can go and write a program
on your laptop that will literally make
you money as you sleep by arbitrage
doing these decentralize exchanges I
think over time in like the
ten twenty thirty year time frame every
price on the internet every amazon.com
you know product will have a
cryptocurrency interface so if you have
some arbitrage strategy for like wool
versus you know fleece sweaters or
whatever you can actually arbitrage
anything because everything will be
priced in crypto that's I think where
the arbitrage stuff goes in the medium
to long term okay fourth point you know
people talk a lot about the potential of
blockchain and I do think it has a lot
of potential but you know it's actually
something where you know in some ways
it's overhype in some ways it's actually
underhyped right there's to say there
are fundamental financial primitives
that the watchings already delivered
like a 10x improvement on and I mean a
quantifiable 10x right so you know the
easy one the obvious one is gold right
so bitcoin is infinitely lighter than
gold okay like it's it's faster
transport internationally it's cheaper
to custody to give a concrete example of
this you know when the the German
Bundesbank
tried to repatriate a bunch of gold from
New York it took them years it costs of
millions of dollars to bring back
billions of dollars in gold and while
that might be an infrequent operation
it's an extremely important valuable
operation that frankly underpins like
you know a big chunk of the world
economy and if you've improved on that
that's that's a big deal right gold is
two trillion dollar industry if that was
the only thing that that block she ended
up doing that'd be a pretty big deal but
but it's more than that um Tom's going
to buy some Bitcoin yeah so it's more
than that like with the with aetherium
you know and other kinds of
cryptocurrencies
that represents a 10x improvement over
Swift right you know Swift
if anybody sent a wire internationally
that takes days to clear typically
whereas with aetherium I can be on the
phone with somebody and just like I can
wait for that email to hit I can wait to
just see it in the blockchain and you
know I could say oh that transaction is
done boom I can you know now now get the
deal closed and so you know this is the
speed difference here is a difference
between like a physical mail like you
know sending sending a letter which
takes two to three days versus an email
which takes you know minutes and think
about how big a difference that made
right like when you went from physical
mail to email just the metabolism of
business changed when you go from 2 to 3
days for international
two minutes the metabolism of
international business changes right
Third Point crowdfunding right so in
2015 if you go to Wikipedia and you look
at the list of the largest crowd funders
okay you will see that it's like you
know maybe 10 million 15 million dollars
by 2017 2018 a large crowd funder was
four billion dollars right so that's
like a four hundred X improvement in
about two to three years and and that's
that's more than 10x that's like you
know 400 X now you might argue well what
are those things funding they're all
funding icos and crypto stuff it's all
this uroboros
but it's actually something where you
could fund a building right you could
fund pretty much anything you know now
that folks are customized using crypto
to do this kind of thing it's it's a
powerful new innovation in crowdfunding
and I can go on and on and and you know
I probably write an article on this but
you know just a few more examples so
like Delaware incorporation right in in
many studies like the World Bank has a
study called doing business and in this
study they actually say hey you know how
long does it take you to incorporate in
your country does it take you weeks or
months or does it take you days and if
takes you days well you're you know a
great country for business great
countries for startups
well the theorems shattered that
destroyed that because it's not days
anymore it's minutes you can literally
get a smart contract into the blockchain
in minutes right and that's amazing that
works internationally you're not
incorporating in Delaware you're
incorporating on the blockchain and it
might seem like an apposite comparison
today but lots and lots of stuff all
these VC terms all of these bits of
Delaware law currently as we speak being
encode into smart contracts so that
incorporation on the blockchain will
become probably the default in like I
don't know 10 or 15 years and you know
there's more like the time to set up
bank accounts the time to audit you know
in 2013 people talked about you know
bitcoin is a scam but today the big four
when they audit a blockchain firm they
use the blockchain as the source of
ground truth that they check all of your
transactions against okay so from a scam
to the gold standard in like five years
and and so that the point here is we're
10x in all of these financial primitives
like basic basic fundamental things and
how we move money how we think about
money and that's gonna have consequences
good concerts is hopefully relatedly
not only have you know watch ins 10x law
of things they've already created many
billion dollar entities right so you
know three that in that of you know
risen in particular you know the folks
who founded new coins the miners who run
these gigantic server farms and the
exchanges and each of these three groups
has created and captured billions of
dollars in total revenue it's comparable
sort of to the 90s Internet when you
know kind of infrastructure stage and
you know search engines and and Akamai
and and you know AOL and so on we're
getting built out at that time sixth now
people talk about blockchains is being
trustless and bitcoin is about you know
no trust I think a much better way of
thinking about it is that they give you
a choice of who to trust
okay so before you just had to trust a
bank right you had to store your money
in a bank you can't just go and you know
withdraw like you know a million dollars
from the bank or you could but you know
you've been a lot of lists and you know
today what you can do is you can
certainly still stored at a bank should
you so desire you can sort with you know
a company like wing base or and this is
very new you can store it on your
computer you can store it on a USB key
you can you know store it in the cloud
and you can basically self custody an
arbitrary amount of money and that's a
major innovation because you know it's
like you can't carry a bunch of gold
bricks around with you you might be able
to carry around suitcases full of cash
but it's a little bit conspicuous and
and now you can carry an arbitrary
amount of money so that's a very new
thing you don't have to trust the bank
if you don't want to and you know places
like that as well this is actually you
know truly a killer app number seven I
hinted at this before but just just to
drill into this point um
one can argue that the single most
important data structure in Silicon
Valley is the cap table right namely the
very simple table that shows you know
which people or entities on what shares
of the company right your common stock
your series seed a B etc right that data
structure that little table that Excel
spreadsheet maintained thing is what has
lined people from every country around
the globe you know in in to build
Silicon Valley and the scale at which
its align them is 10 0
sometimes thousands of people pre-ipo
and then you build this huge company and
then everybody you know hopefully does
well together but you know the the state
of the art for managing the most
important data structure in Silicon
Valley is an Excel spreadsheet or a
Google sheet right there's kind of kind
of amazing and now what we've got with
the blockchain is you can ten or 100 or
1000 X that number of people you know
something like you know bat for example
is 54,000 addresses that hold that and
you can see exactly who owns what went
right and this is fully programmatic so
one way I think about it is if aligning
a few hundred people you know at a time
built Silicon Valley what does aligning
a few hundred thousand people at a time
or a few million people a time what can
that build right so we can now align
human beings and incentivize them like
never before that's that's a really
really big deal so debride uh you know
what am I think about this is you know
like some of you here will be like oh
you know I got to see it for too late I
missed mobile you know it's over no it's
it's not over just beginning so you know
one thing we think of is like blockchain
first or crypto first is like the new
mobile first it provides a weapon with
which to go and attack and open many
industries or areas that are either
close to competition or seemingly
impregnable or not even thought of as a
kind of thing you could innovate on
right so you know Ellery mentions you
know international wires and precious
metals and messaging and i'll talk about
the social bit in a little bit more um
but there's also other areas that are
that you know you normally wouldn't
think of as things you can even innovate
on for example like DNS right with
crypto you can innovate on DNS you can
innovate at the protocol level um you
know with with things like you know
block stack or ens or handshake where
you can register domain names these are
also scarce entities you can register
them in a blockchain and you can route
you know things through them you can
have incentivized versions of BitTorrent
and centralized versions of smtp all
these protocols you know that you
previously thought of as kind of you
know non monetizable are now potentially
improvable and monetizable there's also
you know commons like wikipedia open
source projects where you can take a
fresh gloss in them and think okay how
could I maybe tokenize this how could I
make this even even
better and so you know this type of
stuff you know that there's there's so
many different crypto first companies
that are kind of swarming and attacking
these different verticals that I
couldn't even enumerate all them this
gives you some of the flavor of them
could be aventures alone is made like 40
investments or the course last year
ninth point so blockchains break network
effects okay and they give a completely
new tool a can opener for going after
skilled social networks in two sided
marketplaces one way of thinking about
this is if you think about Metcalfe's
law you think about network utility
typically you know the larger the
network you know the higher the value to
the user so if facebook have two billion
people you know supposedly you know run
away advantage you can't dismiss it
right but there's something really
interesting about crypto which which is
that if you have a token whose value is
associated with the startup the tokens
upside is maximal when the size of the
network is smallest right so for example
an early investor in snapchat had more
upside than somebody who invested in the
series d round where it already had you
know ten million plus users right so
upside is itself valuable and now you've
got a second term in the equation which
can balance out that first term some
kind of hypothetical future value that
for the first time you can
programmatically issue to your users for
sign up and other kinds of actions that
they take within your app right I mean
imagine if Facebook like had something
where the the folks who signed up for it
the first hundred thousand or two
hundred thousand or million users or end
users received some slice of Facebook's
equity for doing that well that'd be a
very big deal you actually start making
money by setting up probablies doing
social apps right so so that's actually
something which i think is a very
powerful tool for going after
scaled social networks two-sided
marketplaces and things like that split
some of the upside with the user tenth
and relatedly block chains I believe are
going to transform social networks so
for the last ten years people of being
you know liking and poking and messaging
each other you know wasting time the
next ten years you know well we've done
making friends as times start making
money right so basically those edges we
think are going to now
have money on them cryptocurrency and
you're gonna have new kinds of social
networks what we're gonna call them
maybe digital economies or crypto
economy is the fundamental difference
being that your time in them is not
wasting your time them is actually like
a form of work where you're actually
remunerated for it right and you know
some of these you know maybe existing
social networks might be able to
retrofit but I think you're gonna have
to construct wholly new social networks
at our base of these kinds of behaviors
from the beginning where earning is is
part of the equation so you know finally
just on on the type of blockchain
blotching is like a partial move away
from the cloud and towards privacy okay
an amazing stat from earlier this year
is that ledger sold its millionth
Hardware wall right now I think of a
hardware wallet actually this is earlier
it last year early early 2018
um I think of a hardware wallet as being
a pretty arcane kind of thing right but
when a million of them have been sold
you're probably eventually gonna have a
billion sold in some form or the other
right and you know one possibility is
Hardware wallets like like a phone
charger or bundled with a phone so you
get like three devices you know the
phone the phone charger the hardware
wallet rather than - there's lots of
different you know distribution models
you could imagine but the fundamental
concept is I think Hardware vaults are
going to become very popular and that's
a move away from the cloud and towards
privacy because the whole concept for
Hardware all it is you're not keeping
your keys in the cloud you're keeping it
locally one possible future model is
something where your data is on the
cloud but it's encrypted with the
private key is that you're using in your
hardware wallet and so nobody can read
it other than you and it's only
decrypted and re-encrypted just in time
I think things like homework encryption
and so on will make that possible
so let me briefly just give ten things
about coinbase and I'll take some
questions
doing a long time I think so you can
think of Quinn base itself as like the
interface between a fiat and crypto and
you know we have both the retail and
like a professional interface and the
fiat side we're building like a Wall
Street 2.0 right like custody and
indexes and commerce and on the crypto
said we're doing like blockchain first
apps like like earn and and couldn't
miss wallet and we work closely with
regulators
you know our goal is to remain you know
the safe legal and trusted part of
crypto and you've got all these licenses
and so on money transfer licenses all
that stuff and our mission is basically
to create a more open financial system
for the world and you know what that
means this is kind of two different
groups of users that would benefit from
that you know the first group are you
know developers investors you know like
power users of money who are trying to
move money around in different kinds of
ways do do fancy things with money and
the second group are the marginalized
you know the folks who are unbanked the
folks who you know do not have bank
accounts both of these folks in
different ways are pushing on the
financer system to make it more open and
and and those are our folks you know
what does that mean by the way what is
it more open financial system mean it
does mean upside to sometimes means
downside upside is that you can raise
thirty five million dollars in 30
seconds or distort permanence is the
downside is there's new kinds of hacks
and new kinds of scams and so on but I
do believe in the medium term you know
will mitigate the downsides of things
like like multi Savior or what have you
you know cumbias we're kind of thinking
of ourselves as bridging from the
investment phase to the utility phase
which is to say that Krypton has sort of
the opposite emergence model of social
media social media piled up the users
first and then had to prove out
monetization and crypto proved that
monetization first in almost the most
literal sense and now needs to prove out
utility right um but we're seeing that
happen you know I can go to lots of
different things would earn would
decentralized finance and we think
that's a big part of the next you know
five years or cellphone claim is
actually named after where the
blockchain starts so the so-called
coinbase transaction is where the new
crypto is created in Bitcoin and that's
why you know we think it's also where
the blockchain starts for users right
just like you know Windows you started
using it you know the start button or
Google searches where you started
browsing the internet you know log on
the Facebook how you started using
social media couldn't this is where you
start using crypto right so we think of
ourselves as kind of like this sort of
on-ramp this is the start button for
crypto we're making headlines you can
read about more about us online and
that's about it
you
[Applause]